next we're going to talk about recurring
recurrent neural networks
and we'll go back to this document
document classification example
in the in the chapter we described using
a lstm recurrent neural network
um and that's what we're going to
implement here
so
the first thing i do is
look at the average length of of the
documents this is the word count in the
document so it's about 178
and
91 percent of them had less than or
equal to 500 words
this gives us a sense of the size of the
documents because you call for re recall
for recurrent neural networks we want
sequences of the same length so in this
case the sequences are the sequences of
words in the document
the feature for each document is going
to be the sequences of words and we want
them to be the same length
and so
based on this little exploration
we'll limit the words to be 500 words
per review
and
if the review's longer than that we'll
just truncate
and if it's shorter than that we'll pad
it with blanks so that's why i remember
the the idea of recurrent neural
networks versus bag of words
black words just used the presence or
absence of a word but now we're going to
use the order in which they appear
that's right rob yeah so now we think of
a document as a sequence of words
and of course this is a sequence of
these one hot encoded words so
the the feature vector for each word is
a very sparse 10 000 dimensional
vector with just one one right and zero
is elsewhere
right so that's the input for a
um
a recurrent neural network
although
we can use an embedding
one of these learned embeddings
to reduce the dimension
okay so here we go
reading in the data doing the padding of
the sequences
and
i just show the the last
the last 10 words in in one of the
the sequences and these are just indices
of words in the document
so at this point it just stores each
document as
dictionary indices for the words
so the first layer of the recurrent
neural network is going to be an
embedding layer of size 32
and then we're going to learn that
during training
so rather than encode the word
as a one hot encoding with 10 000
elements and only one of them one
we're going to learn an embedding layer
which has just got 32
elements and so you'll go from the digit
label
to a 32 vector
and that embedding layer is going to be
learned
so that's the specification here layer
embedding
you can think of it as
as multiplying this binary vector by the
the matrix but it's done more
efficiently than that
and then
the hidden units which are themselves
the sequence in the recurrent neural
network are going to have
themselves 32 units
and then the output is just the
sentiment of the document it's just a
single variable
so that's how we
specify that
we'll give it three epochs you'll see
that the recurrent neural network is is
pretty slow
we'll use a batch size of 128
and and then we'll make predictions
we may even stop this if it takes too
long
you can see it chugging through
remember there was 25 000 training
observations 25 000 tests so these are
training documents
so
it's taken it's going to take a long
time
so
we're going to stop that
it doesn't do very well anyway
it did actually
worse than the
than the glimnet
and
just a regular uh neural network
on the bag of words in the bag of new
words yeah so it did worse so we stop it
okay
well when you're in the end the last
topic is is time series prediction
um
so
i see the section numbers didn't appear
yet but
we can fix that
this is the new york stock exchange
where
recall we had the sequence for the dow
jones return
the log volume and log volatility
for
a number of years
the data is in the islr2 package so
we'll
we'll read it in
and we scale the data the to to have
unit variance and mean zero
and there's a designated training and
test set on on the data set
so is train is a binary variable which
is true for each year that is in the
training set and false for each years in
the test set
and if you recall
the first number of years were training
data and the subsequent years were test
data which is often what we do
with these kind of time series data
because of the the series or
autocorrelation in the data
rather than randomly mix up the training
and test data in the time series well
you want to predict the future from the
past yes right exactly
so we want to create lags so we write a
little function for computing lags and
you can dig into that and see what it
does
and
if you recall in the in the
in the chapter um we created a model
matrix
for autoregression
where
the x
the the the in other words an x matrix
where the features were the response
lagged one day two days
up to five days back
and also the other two features so the
response is is
log volume
but log volatility and dojo returns
were also features and we also use them
at those lags
and so that's what we do here
we use our lag function that we created
to create a data frame that has all of
those in them
if we look at the first five rows we'll
see we have some missing data
because at the beginning of the series
we can't make lags going backwards so
we're going to remove those
and there'll be five of them that we
need to remove okay and so that's what
we do there
now we'll just fit a linear regression
model
i think at this point let's just show
let's just show
some of the
rows of a or frame
i'll just look at the first
three rows
so there's the response it's going to be
log volume
and now you see lag one dow jones return
lag one log volume lag one log
volatility
lag two and so on so it's created those
legs for us
up to lag five
okay
and
okay so now we fit a linear model and we
make predictions
and then we compute an r squared and
these are the lines for computing the r
squared we none we want the null
variance
and then the prediction error
the mean squared error and turn it into
an r squared and we get
41
is that good wrong
i
anything to do with the stock market
that's 41 sounds pretty impressive
exactly
now it would be nice if we could predict
the stock price right with 41 accuracy
but it turns out log volumes the volume
traded on a given day is is i think
easier to to predict
we saw in the text that if you added day
of the week
so each of the days in this these data
is a trading day and they occur on days
of the week and some days of the week
have higher volume often at the
beginning or end of the week so we're
going to add that as a
it's a factor variable we're going to
just add it to the model and refit
and we see that the the r squared goes
up to 46 percent
which is clearly that's an important
variable right
so we now use an rnn to fit these data
and
the rnn expects
something a little different right it
expects a little sequence
expects a data set
of sequences right
so the sequence in this case is for each
day
the sequence is the sequence of lagged
days
and at each lag day we've got a three
vector which are the three
measures that we have right
so it's they're short sequences they're
going to be sequences of length five but
those are the sequences that go into the
rnn
okay and that's described in in detail
in in in the book
right so we can see there's
6046 training
days
the sequences of length 5 and each of
them is a 3 vector
okay
and now we fit the rn in
the the
these structures start looking the same
after a while here we include dropout
this was after a little bit of trial and
error
the the hidden layer which is this again
is a sequence they're going to have 12
units
and these are the details for the rnn
and
we fit the the model similar to what we
did before so this is going to amount to
sort of a non-linear time ar model is
that right it's a it's a it's a funny
thing rob yeah
not quite a non-linear ar model because
it's it's got the same it uses remember
for the rnn in the in the structure that
we described it's got the same weights
for each of the
hidden units right
right and the hidden units is a sequence
of five hidden units so the same weights
take
the input into the hidden unit
and the
the previous hidden unit to the next
hidden unit so it's a different
structure
in a little bit we'll we'll we'll
actually flatten
the neural network and we will do a
non-linear ar model
but the rnn is a bit different
and like all rnns it takes a while
rnns tend to be slow in our experience
to
some of the other neural network models
but it seems to flatten off
and
we've we've got a validation data set
i believe in this case just the test
data set and and that's in green
and
when we
let's
see somewhere down here it's telling us
how well we did
and it got 41 percent
as well r squared at 45 before it was
this day of week in here or day of weeks
not in years
weeks not in yet
so it doesn't do any better than the
than just the simple autoregressive
model in this case
okay
it takes about a
less than a minute to train
and
here's the one that you were referring
to rob this is where we actually don't
fit it using a
an rnn
but we we we just flatten it and fit it
as a neural network and by flattening
what that means is that it just creates
basically the same features that we used
in the autoregressive model
and if we fit that model
let's see that would that would do it
what we do here is we actually have the
model
that was used for the for the linear
model autoregressive model
and
we can just use that and fit a
neural network on that and that's what
we do over here
and
what you'll see is that it
it gets the same performance as the
as the autoregressive model
and it's it's given us some plots
and in the r console
we see on this used day of the week as
well and it gets the same results as the
water regressive model so i guess we're
seeing here that you know all the hype
about deep learning it is a great thing
but we there's also a lot of cases where
it doesn't do better than these simple
models right and we've seen now two or
three that's right that's right rob and
and in cases like that so you're the
autoregressive model it's a well-known
and simple you know
popular model
performed as well yeah and if you have a
case like that you'd rather use it
because you might understand it better
and explain it better explain it better
yeah also for the sentiment um the
the glimnet lasso model did as well as
the neural network right
but on these other models like the image
classification it's really hard to beat
a neural network yeah they they
you know that's the way to go
okay well that's the end of this lab and
uh
that and so this lab is showing you how
to use um keras and tensorflow to fit
neural network models
and there's other ways of doing that
right now
yeah i mean it seems that more people
are using pi torch pi torch
which is also a python package for fit
in
[Music]
deep learning models
so we will have available on our website
some pie torch versions of these
exercises right in fact um there's a
torch package
developed by our studio this keras was
developed by our studio studio and
there's a torch package developed as
well
and
in a short while we'll have an
implementation of this lab in torch it's
actually been translated by a team at
our studio and
by the maybe by the time you see this
this lecture that will be available as
well
so thank you